so let's talk a little bit about how to
Compare costs based on all of your
college options so the biggest piece of
cost is going to be your tuition and
then of course your living expenses room
and board where you're going to live and
what you're going to eat and how you're
going to eat it and then there's a bunch
of other expenses there's going to be
travel and entertainment and everyone
needs a little bit of entertainment and
especially if you're going to a college
or one of your options is to go to
college where you might have to travel
by air well that could get a little bit
more expensive and then there's all
these other incidentals things like
textbooks and lab fees Etc
and so the first thing I would do is uh
when you get your various options and
it's good to have as many options as
possible within reason is try to add all
of that up and now one thing I want to
make sure you keep in mind is the
sticker cost you know when a university
just says our tuition is X that's not
necessarily what you have to pay and
there's many ways for you to pay it in
many cases if you come from a family
that does not have a high income you can
get significant financial aid now that
financial aid can be the form of
scholarship it could be just a straight
up Grant based on your your family's
need or it could be some type of a loan
now once you have your options and you
know what type of Aid you can get for
your different options then you need to
just compare them and generally speaking
before you consider financial aid your
least expensive options are probably
going to be something like going to a
community college close to home and even
if your goal is a four-year degree in
many states I know out here in
California you can go to a community
college for two years and it's actually
kind of a program to transfer then into
four-year colleges so that could be an
option that could be cheaper you could
live at home the tuition tends to be a
lot cheaper at the local community
college and then when you're ready to
transfer you could transfer
the next most expensive option or the
next
um higher price option is usually going
to some form of a state school either a
city school or a state school
where uh there they give a special
tuition for in-state residents uh if
you're strong academically there might
also be schools that give you academic
scholarships and then you have a bunch
of private schools that usually have
higher tuition than for sure the state
schools and and the community colleges
and there the key is is to not make your
decision until you know whether they're
going to give you financial aid and and
how what kind of financial aid that is
obviously scholarships and grants are a
lot better than loans but then once you
have all of that information you can
make your decision and don't make your
decision purely on cost or purely on
price it might be tempting to say oh I'm
going to end up with a four-year degree
no matter what let me just take the
cheapest possible option that might be a
good idea but ask a lot of questions it
might turn out that maybe one option is
a little bit more expensive even after
you consider financial aid but when you
talk to recent graduates they say hey
that was an amazing experience it helped
me grow so much and maybe the career
services there or there's just a lot of
recruiters that go to that campus that
would not go to the other campuses and
so their job prospects are a lot better
and so it's not just the cost you're
making an investment in yourself so it's
not just the cost you have to see the
return on on that cost you know so if
you're investing in two stocks it
wouldn't it wouldn't be that the dollar
stock is better than the two dollar
stock uh if the two dollar stock is
going to give you a better return same
thing about a colleges now I won't say
the expensive one is also always going
to be the best one either you really
have to think what you're going to be
putting in and then what you think
you'll likely get out and also where are
you going to thrive because if you go to
a place where you're not happy where
you're not engaged well then that's
really kind of setting yourself up for
for a not optimal situation